in our new series our series the new
normal rather we look at how the
pandemic is dramatically changing our
everyday lives
a recent survey estimates that when the
health crisis is over around 30 percent
of the workforce will still be working
from home at least a couple of times a
week for Americans going back to the
office it will be anything but business
as usual Jamie yuccas shows us how
workspaces are being adapted to keep
people safe from the coronavirus
modifications have begun at the office
of CBR e in Atlanta to ensure this
fortune 500 real estate firm encourages
safety once its workers return when you
be doing is CBR ease executive managing
director he's overseeing changes to
mitigate transmission of the virus is
this about not only creating safety
around their physical space but also
their psychological space certainly any
preparations we make will not be
effective and I think people are anxious
to help employees cope with change the
company created this virtual walkthrough
showing the new directional flow of foot
traffic and decreased density so it's
kind of getting comfortable visualizing
what the space is going to look like but
those are the kinds of things I think
people mentally ready to go into that
space and say yeah I can do this some
offices are opting for physical barriers
that's been a boon for Plexiglas
manufacturer mark Cannavaro
the items that people need right now to
get back to work are in such high demand
it's unprecedented in a million years
you could have never thought that this
would have happened as the pandemic took
hold thousands of orders poured in from
across the country cubicles are on a
comeback
there's so much beer I have it I feel
like people are still gonna feel more
comfortable if there's something there
if you put up a plexiglass divider you
can at least still see someone talk to
them connect wired editor-in-chief Nick
Thompson says the new normal will also
include high tech tools like thermal
cameras to scan body temperatures
advanced industrial marketing is
offering location monitoring systems to
track how close employees get to one
another well the goal is safety not
surveillance Thompson says that's coming
too
the kind of creepy thing will come when
people install surveillance cameras in
elevators and they start to monitor
employees and that's when you start to
get privacy trade-offs to see social
changes firsthand wire documented
employees returning to work in China you
still eat at the company cafeteria but
you have to eat out of a special box
that you kind of put around your head
creating a private space in high-rise
office buildings staggered schedules
will be needed to reduce wait times for
elevators and touchless entries will be
part of the new normal and we might see
the end of the water cooler and the end
of the coffee station but isn't that
part of the point of going into the
office is to have human connection
we are craving real life connections
right now we're gonna have to design
offices in ways that minimize those real
life connections for now open floor
plans and face to face meetings may
become relics of the past the immediate
future is a workplace that supports
wellness as it awaits the arrival of a
vaccine for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Vista California listen we
just all want to be safe we've seen it
already there at CBS you know in the
elevator how they have the signs and
leading up to the elevator I think it's
a good thing but I'm not ready to give
up the wallet water cooler yet good
stuff happens at the water cooler
ketchup want to be careful I don't want
to be careful I will miss the water
cooler I will miss the coffee machine
and that like that box that you eat your
lunch out of we saw
I don't know how will I talk about what
to watch later kick things the elevator
elevator kick thing yeah I like that it
really talked about with the air in
there too right yes and we can do it we
can do it we can do it